The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I want to start where
we left off.
You remember last time we were
looking at Fibonacci.
And so we've got it up here,
a nice little recursive
implementation of it.
And the thing I wanted to point
out is, we've got this
global variable number
of calls.
Which is there not because
Fibonacci needs it but just
for pedagogical reasons, so that
we can keep track of how
much work this thing is doing.
And I've turned on a print
statement which
was off last time.
So we can see what it's
doing is it runs.
So let's try it here
with Fib of 6.
So, as we would hope, Fib
of 6 happens to be 8.
That right?
That right, everybody?
Should Fib of 6 be 8?
I don't think so.
So first thing we should do is
scratch our heads and see
what's going on here.
Alright, let's look at it.
What's happening here?
This is your morning
wake-up call.
What is happening?
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: See if I can get it
all the way to the back.
No I can't.
That's embarrassing.
Alright.
So if n is less than or
equal to 1, return n.
Well that's not right, right?
What should I be doing there?
Because Fib of 0 is?
What?
1.
So let's fix it.
How about that, right?
Or maybe, what would be even
simpler than that?
Maybe I should just do that.
Now let's try it.
We feel better about this?
We like that answer?
Yes, no?
What's the answer, guys?
What should Fibonacci of 6 be?
I think that's the right
answer, right?
OK.
So what do I want you to
notice about this?
I've computed a value
which is 13.
And it's taken me 25 calls.
25 recursive calls
to get there.
Why is it taking so many?
Well, what we can see here is
that I'm computing the same
value over and over again.
Because if we look at the
recursive structure of the
program, what we'll see that's
going on here is, I call Fib
of 5 and 4, but then Fib
of 5 is also going
to call Fib of 4.
So I'm going to be computing
it on those branches.
And then it gets worse and
worse as I go down.
So if I think about computing
Fib of 0 I'm going to be
computing that a lot of times.
Now, fortunately, Fib
of 0 is short.
But the other ones
are not so short.
And so what I see is that as I
run this, I'm doing a lot of
redundant computation.
Computing values whose answer
I should already know.
That's, you'll remember last
time, I talked about the
notion of overlapping
sub-problems. And that's what
we have here.
As with many recursive
algorithms, I solve a bigger
problem by solving a
smaller instance of
the original problem.
But here there's overlap.
The instant unlike binary
search, where each instance
was separate, here the
instances overlap.
They share something
in common.
In fact, they share quite
a lot in common.
That's not unusual.
That will lead me to use a
technique I mentioned again
last time, called memoization.
Effectively, what that says
is, we record a value the
first time it's computed, then
look it up the subsequent
times we need it.
So it makes sense.
If I know I'm going to need
something over and over again,
I squirrel it away somewhere
and then get it
back when I need it.
So let's look at an
example of that.
So I'm going to have something
called fast Fib.
But first I'm going to have,
let's look at what fast Fib
does and then we'll come back
to the next question.
It takes the number whose
Fibonacci I want plus a memo.
And the memo will be a
dictionary that maps me from a
number to Fib of that number.
So what I'm going to do, well,
let's get rid of this print
statement for now.
I'm going to say, if
n is not in memo.
Remember the way dictionary
works, this is the key.
Is the key of a value.
Then I'll call fast Fib
recursively, with n minus 1 in
memo, and n minus 2 in memo.
Otherwise I'll return
the memo.
Well, let's look at
it for a second.
This is the basic idea.
But do we actually believe
this is going to work?
And, again, I want you to look
at this and think about what's
going to happen here.
Before we do that, or as you do
that, let's look at Fib 1.
The key thing to notice about
Fib 1 is that it has the same
specification as Fib.
Because when somebody calls
Fibonacci, they shouldn't
worry about memos.
And how I'd implemented it.
That has to be under
the covers.
So I don't want them
to have to call
something with two arguments.
The integer and the memo.
So I'll create Fib 1, which has
the same arguments as Fib.
The first thing it does is
it initializes the memo.
And initializes it by saying,
if I get 0 I -- whoops.
Aha.
Let's be careful here.
If I get 0 I return 1.
I get 1, I return 1.
So I put two things in
the memo already.
And then I'll call fast
Fib and it returns
the result it has.
So you see the basic idea.
I take something with the same
parameters as the original.
Add this memo.
Give it some initial values.
And then call.
So now what do we think?
Is this going to work?
Or is there an issue here?
What do you think?
Think it through.
If it's not in the memo, I'll
compute its value and put it
in the memo.
And then I'll return it.
OK?
If it was already there,
I just look it up.
That make sense to everybody?
Let's see what happens
if we run it.
Well, actually, let's turn the
print statement on, since
we're doing it with a
small value here.
So what we've seen is I've
run it twice here.
When I ran it up here, with the
old Fib, and we printed
the result, and I ran it
with Fib 1 down here.
The good news is we
got 13 both times.
The even better news is that
instead of 25 calls, it was
only 11 calls.
So it's a big improvement.
Let's see what happens, just to
get an idea of how big the
improvement is.
I'm going to take out the
two print statements.
And let's try it with
a bigger number.
It's going to take
a little bit.
Well, look at this difference.
It's 2,692,537 versus 59.
That's a pretty darn
big difference.
And I won't ask you to
check whether it
got the right answer.
At least, not in your heads.
So you can see, and this is an
important thing we look at, is
that as we look at growth, it
didn't look like it mattered a
lot with 6.
Because it was one small
number to one
slightly smaller number.
But this thing grows
exponentially.
It's a little bit complicated
exactly how.
But you can see as I go up to 30
I get a pretty big number.
And 59 is a pretty
small number.
So we see that the memoization
here is buying me
a tremendous advantage.
And this is what lies at the
heart of this very general
technique called dynamic
programming.
And in fact, it lies at the
heart of a lot of useful
computational techniques
where we save results.
So if you think about the way
something like, say, Mapquest
works, and last week in
recitation you looked at the
fact that shortest path
is exponential.
Well, what it does is it
saves a lot of paths.
It kind of knows people are
going to ask how do you get
from Boston to New York City.
And it may have saved that.
And if you're going from Boston
to someplace else where
New York just happens to be on
the way, it doesn't have to
recompute that part of it.
So it's saved a lot of things
and squirreled them away.
And that's essentially what
we're doing here.
Here we're doing it as part
of one algorithm.
There, they're just storing a
database of previously solved
problems. And relying on
something called table lookup,
Of which memoization
is a special case.
But table lookup
is very common.
When you do something
complicated you save the
answers and then you
go get it later.
I should add that in some
sense this is a phony
straw-man Fibonacci.
Nobody in their right mind
actually implements a
recursive Fibonacci the way
I did it originally.
Because the right way to
do it is iteratively.
And the right way to do it is
not starting at the top, it's
starting at the bottom.
And so you can piece it
together that way.
But don't worry about it, it's
not, I'm just using it because
it's a simpler example than the
one I really want to get
to, which is knapsack.
OK, people get this?
And see the basic idea and
why it's wonderful?
Alright.
Now, when we talked about
optimization problems in
dynamic programming, I
said there were two
things to look for.
One was overlapping
sub-problems. And the other
one was optimal substructure.
The notion here is that you
can get a globally optimal
solution from locally optimal
solutions to sub-problems.
This is not true of all
problems. But as we'll see,
it's true of a lot of problems.
And when you have an
optimal substructure and the
local solutions overlap,
that's when you can bring
dynamic programming to bear.
So when you're trying to think
about is this a problem that I
can solve with dynamic
programming, these are the two
questions you ask.
Let's now go back and
instantiate these ideas for
the knapsack problem we
looked at last time.
In particular, for the
0-1 knapsack problem.
So, we have a collection
of objects.
We'll call it a.
And for each object in
0, we have a value.
In a, we have a value.
And now we want to find the
subset of a that has the
maximum value, subject to
the weight constraint.
I'm just repeating
the problem.
Now, what we saw last
time is there's
a brute force solution.
As you have discovered in recent
problem set, it is
possible to construct all
subsets of a set.
And so you could construct all
subsets, check that the weight
is less than the weight of the
knapsack, and then choose the
subset with the maximum value.
Or a subset with the maximum
value, there may be more than
one, and you're done.
On the other hand, we've seen
that if the size of a is n,
that's to say, we have n
elements to choose from, then
the number of possible subsets
is 2 to the n.
Remember, we saw that
last time looking
at the binary numbers.
2 to the n is a big number.
And maybe we don't have to
consider them all, because we
can say, oh this one is going
to be way too big.
It's going to weigh too much,
we don't need to look at it.
But it'll still be
order 2 to the n.
If n is something like 50, not a
big number, 2 to the 50 is a
huge number.
So let's ask, is there
an optimal
substructure to this problem.
That would let us tackle it
with dynamic programming.
And we're going to do this
initially by looking at a
straightforward implementation
based upon what's called the
decision tree.
This is a very important
concept, and we'll see a lot
of algorithms essentially
implement decision trees.
Let's look at an example.
Let's assume that the weights,
and I'll try a really small
example to start with, are 5,
3 and 2, and the values,
corresponding values,
are 9, 7 and 8.
And the maximum, we'll
say, is 5.
So what we do is, we start by
considering for each item
whether to take it or not.
For reasons that will become
apparent when we implement it
in code, I'm going to
start at the back.
The last element in the list.
And what I'm going to use is
the index of that element to
keep track of where I am.
So I'm not going to worry
whether this item is a vase or
a watch or painting.
I'm just going to say it's
the n'th element.
Where n'th is somewhere between
0 and 2 in this case.
And then we'll construct our
tree as follows: each node,
well, let me put an
example here.
The first node will be the
to-pull 2, 5 and 0.
Standing for, let me make sure I
get this in the right order,
well, the index which is 2, the
last element in this case,
so that's the index.
This is the weight
still available.
If you see that in the shadow.
And this is the value
currently obtained.
So I haven't included
anything.
Means I have all
5 pounds left.
But I don't have anything
of value.
Now, the decision tree,
if I branch left,
it's a binary tree.
This is going to
be don't take.
So I'm not going to take the
item with an index of 2.
So that means this node will
have an index of 1.
Next item to be considered, I
still have 5 pounds available.
And I have 0 value.
To be systematic, I'm going to
build this tree depth-first
left-first. At each node, I'm
going to go left until I can't
go any further.
So we'll take another don't-take
branch here.
And what is this node
going to look like?
Pardon?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 0, 5, 0.
And then we'll go one more.
And I'll just put a minus
indicating I'm done.
I can't look below that.
I still have five pounds left,
and I still have zero value.
The next thing I'm going
to do is backtrack.
That is to say, I'm going
to go back to a node
I've already visited.
Go up the tree 1.
And now, of course, the only
place to go is right.
And now I get to include
something.
Yeah.
And what does this
node look like?
Well, I'll give you a hint,
it starts with a minus.
What next?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Pardon.
0.
And?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
5.
Alright.
So far, this looks
like the winner.
But, we'd better keep going.
We backtrack to here again.
There's nothing useful to do.
We backtrack to here.
And we ask, what do we
get with this node?
0, 3.
Somebody?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Louder.
2.
And then?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: There's a value
here, what's this value?
I've included item number 1,
which has a value of 7.
Right?
So now this looks
like the winner.
Pardon?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This one?
STUDENT: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Remember, I'm
working from the back.
So it shouldn't be 9.
Should be what?
Item 0, oh, you're right,
items 0 is 9.
Thank you.
Right you are.
Still looks like the winner.
I can't hear you.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Let's be careful
about this.
I'm glad people are watching.
So we're here.
And now we've got 5
pounds available.
That's good.
And we're considering
item number 0.
Which happens to
weigh 5 pounds.
So that's a good thing.
So, it's the last item
to consider.
If we include it, we'll
have nothing left.
Because we had 5 and
we're using all 5.
So that will be 0.
And its value is 9.
So we put one item in the
backpack and we've
got a value of 9.
Anyone have a problem
with that?
So far, so good?
Now we've backed up to here.
We're considering item 1 and
we're trying to ask whether we
can put it in.
Item 1 has a weight of 3.
So it would fit.
And if we use it, we
have 2 pounds left.
And item 1 has a value of 7.
So if we did this, we'd
have a value of 7.
But we're not done yet, right?
We still have some things
to consider.
Well, we could consider
not putting in item 0.
That makes perfect sense.
And we're back to where we're
there, minus 2 and 7.
And now let's ask the question
how, about putting in item 0.
Well, we can't.
Because it would weigh 5 pounds,
I only have 2 left.
So there is no right
branch to this one.
So I'm making whatever
decisions I can
make along the way.
Let's back up to here.
And now we're going to ask
about taking item 2.
If we take item 2, then, well,
the index after that will of
course be 1.
And the available weight
will be 3.
And the value will
be 8, right?
Alright, now we say,
can I take item 1.
Yeah.
I can.
It only weighs 3 and I happen
to have 3 left.
So that's good.
Don't take it, right.
Sorry.
This is the don't take branch.
So I go to 0, 3, 8.
And then I can do another
don't take branch.
And this gets me to
what, minus 3, 8.
I'll now back up.
And I'll say, alright, suppose I
do take item 0, well I can't
take item 0, right?
Weighs too much.
So, don't have that branch.
Back up to here.
Alright, can I take item 1?
Yes, I can.
And that gives me what?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: We have a winner.
So it's kind of tedious,
but it's important
to see that it works.
It's systematic.
I have a way of exploring
the possible solutions.
And at the end I choose
the winner.
What's the complexity of this
decision tree solution?
Well, in the worst case, we're
enumerating every possibility
of in and out.
Now I've shortened it a little
bit by saying, ah, we've run
out of weight, we're OK.
But effectively it is, as we
saw before, exponential.
2 to the n, every value in the
bit vector we looked at last
time is either 0 or 1.
So it's a binary number
of n bits, 2 to the n.
Let's look at a straightforward
implementation of this.
I'll get rid of Fibonacci here,
we don't want to bother
looking at that again.
Hold on a second until I
comment this out, yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
There's a branch we could finish
here, but since we're
out of weight we sort of know
we're going to be done.
So we could complete it.
But it's not very interesting.
But yes, we probably should
have done that.
So let's look at an
implementation here.
Whoops.
You had these in the handout,
by the way.
So here's max val.
It takes four arguments.
The weight, w, and v,
these are the two
vectors we've seen here.
Of the weights and the values.
It takes i, which is in some
sense the length of those
vectors, minus 1, because
of the way Python works.
So that gives me my index.
And the amount of weight
available, a w,
for available weight.
So again, I put in this num
calls, which you can ignore.
First line says, if i is 0, that
means I'm looking at the
very last element.
Then if the weight of i is
less than the available
weight, I can return
the value of i.
Otherwise it's 0.
I've got one element
to look at.
I either put it in if I can.
If I can't, I don't.
Alright, so if I'm at the end of
the chain, that's my value.
In either event, if
I'm looking at the
last element, I return.
The next line says alright,
suppose I don't, I'm not at
the last element.
Suppose I don't include it.
Then the maximum value I can
get is the maximum value of
what I had.
But with index i minus 1.
So that's the don't-take
branch.
As we've seen systematically in
the don't-takes, the only
thing that gets changed
is the index.
The next line says if the weight
of i is greater than a
w, well then I know
I can't put it in.
So I might as well return
the without i
value I just computed.
Otherwise, let's see
what I get with i.
And so the value of with i will
be the value of i plus
whatever I can get using
the remaining items and
decrementing the weight
by the weight of i.
So that's exactly what
we see as we go
down the right branches.
I look at the rest
of the list, but
I've changed the value.
And I've changed the
available weight.
And then when I get to the very
end, I'm going to return
the bigger of with
i and without i.
I've computed the value
if I include i.
I computed the value if
I don't include i.
And then I'm going to just
return the bigger of the two.
Little bit complicated, but
it's basically just
implementing this
decision tree.
Let's see what happens
if we run it.
Well, what I always do in
anything like this is, the
first thing I do is, I run it
on something where I can
actually compute the
answer in my head.
So I get a sense of whether or
not I'm doing the right thing.
So here's a little example.
And I'm going to pause for a
minute, before I run it, and
ask each of you to compute in
your head what you think the
answer should be.
In line with what I said
about debugging.
Always guess before you run your
program what you think
it's going to do.
And I'm going to wait until
somebody raises their hand and
gives me an answer.
Yes.
STUDENT: 29?
PROFESSOR: So we have a
hypothesis that the answer
should be 29.
Ooh.
That's bad.
So as people in the back are
answering these questions
because they want
to test my arm.
The camera probably didn't
catch that, but it was a
perfect throw.
Anyone else think it's 29?
Anyone think it's not 29?
What do you think it is?
Pardon
STUDENT: 62?
PROFESSOR: 62.
That would be impressive.
62.
Alright, well, we have
a guess of 62.
Well, let's run it and see.
29 it is.
And it made a total
of 13 calls.
It didn't do this little
optimization I did over here.
But it gives us our answer.
So that's pretty good.
Let's try a slightly
larger example.
So here I'm going to use
the example we had
in class last time.
This was the burglar example
where they had two copies of
everything.
Here, it gets a maximum value
of 48 and 85 calls.
So we see that I've doubled
the size of the vector but
I've much more than doubled
the number of calls.
This is one of these properties
of this kind of
exponential growth.
Well, let's be really
brave here.
And let's try a really
big vector.
So this particular vector, you
probably can't even see the
whole thing on your screen.
Well, it's got 40 items in it.
Let's see what happens here.
Alright, who wants to tell me
what the answer is while this
computes away?
Nobody in their right mind.
I can tell you the answer, but
that's because I've cheated,
run the program before.
Alright, this is going
to take a while.
And why is it going
to take a while?
Actually it's not 40, I think
these are, alright.
So the answer is 75
and the number of
calls is 1.7 million.
Pardon?
17 million.
Computers are fast,
fortunately.
Well, that's a lot of calls.
Let's try and figure out
what's going on.
But let's not try and figure out
what's going on with this
big, big example because
we'll get really tired.
Oh.
Actually, before we do that,
just for fun, what I want to
do is write down for future
reference, as we look at a
fast one, that the answer is 75
and Eric, how many calls?
240,000.
Alright.
We'll come back to
those numbers.
Let's look at it with
a smaller example.
We'll look at our
example of 8.
That we looked at before.
And we'll turn on this
print statement.
Ooh, what was that?
Notice that I'm only
printing i and a w.
Why is that?
Because w and v are constant.
I don't want you to print them
over and over again.
No, I'd better call it.
That would be a good
thing to do, right?
So let's see.
We'll call it with this one.
So it's printing a lot.
It'll print, I think,
85 calls.
And the thing you should notice
here is that it's doing
a lot of the same things
over and over again.
So, for example, we'll
see 2, 1 here.
And 2, 1 here.
Just like Fibonacci, it's doing
the same work over and
over again.
So what's the solution?
Well, you won't be
surprised to hear
it's the same solution.
So let's look at that code.
So I'm going to do exactly the
same trick we did before.
I don't want b to
the Fibonacci.
I'm going to introduce a max val
0, which has exactly the
same arguments as max val.
Here I'll initiate the memo to
be 0, or to be empty, rather,
the dictionary.
And then I'll call fast max
val passing at this extra
argument of the memo.
So the first thing I'm going to
do is, I'm going to try and
return the value in the memo.
This is a good thing
to do, right?
If it's not already there,
what will happen?
It will raise an exception.
And I'll go to the
except clause.
So I'm using the Python try
except to check whether or not
the thing is in the
memo or not.
I try and return the value.
If it's there, I return it.
If not I'll get a key error.
And what do I do if
I get a key error?
Well, now I go through code very
much like what I did for
max val in the first place.
I check whether it's 0,
et cetera, et cetera.
It's exactly, really, the same,
except before I return
the value I would have returned
I squirrel it away in
my memo for future use.
So it's the same structure
as before.
Except, before I return
the value, I save it.
So the next time I need
it, I can look it up.
Let's see if it works.
Well, let's do a small
example first. It's
calling the old max val.
With all those print
statements.
Sorry about that.
But we'll let it run.
Well, it's a little bit better.
It got 85.
Same answer, but 50 calls
instead of 85.
But let's try the big one.
Because we're really brave.
So here's where we have 30
elements, and a maximum
weight of 40.
I'm not going to call the other
max val here, because we
know what happens
when I do that.
I've created my own little
memo over there.
And let's let it rip.
Wow.
Well, I got the same answer.
That's a good thing.
And instead of 17 million calls,
I have 1800 calls.
That's a huge improvement.
And that's sort of the magic
of dynamic programming.
On Thursday we'll do a more
careful analysis and try and
understand how I could have
accomplished this seemingly
magical task of solving
an exponential
problem so really quickly.